what are the odds that a no-name
eighteenth-century Presbyterian minister
held the key to making artificial
intelligence a reality while Ben
Franklin is running around flying kites
Thomas Bayes is figuring out how to make
educated mathematical guesses in
situations where you don't have that
much to go on like possibly the
probability that this guy exists but
then Bayes dines before he's had a
chance to tell anyone what he's been up
to soon after his philosopher buddy
Richard price discovers bayes's
notebooks while digging around his
apartment looking for free schwag price
is a pretty smart guy so he instantly
recognizes the genius of his pals theory
in 1763 he cleans up the math and
publishes it in an obscure journal
before using it to revolutionize the
insurance business where they need
probabilities to figure out how much to
rip you off by fast forward to 1812
while the US and England are added again
a French guy named Pierre Simone Laplace
develops bayes's theory into something
more usable which becomes known as
conditional probability it lets you
update your guesses with any new facts
that might come your way like this say
the probability of getting dengue fever
while visiting Bermuda for a week is 1
in 10,000 or 0.01%
I'm totally making this up you go to
Bermuda come home and to be safe take a
test that it's 99.9% accurate in
detecting the virus your test comes back
positive you start to freak out
saying goodbye to loved ones writing out
your will and are about to adopt a new
religion when you take a second Bayesian
look at the results remember for every
one person with the virus
there are 9999 people without it which
means that even a robot programmed to
always spit out a negative test result
regardless of who's taking the test
would still guess correctly 99.99% at a
time
being accurate 99.9% of the time then
isn't really that impressive what you
really need to figure out is how
accurate that test is when it spits out
a positive result when this one person
with the virus takes a test chances are
99.9% that it'll be accurate out of the
9999 people without the virus taking the
test 99.9 percent of them will get an
accurate test result which translates to
nine thousand nine hundred eighty nine
people that means that the remaining 10
people will be inaccurately diagnosed
testing positive for dengue fever when
they don't actually have it so out of
the 11 people testing positive for the
dengue virus only one of them actually
has it meaning
the chances your positive test result is
right is only one in 11 or nine percent
not 99.9 percent now swap Engh a fever
with HIV and you're looking at an actual
real-life example people have found
themselves in conditional probability
works pretty well and can literally save
your life but the big thinkers of the
day aren't impressed with the phrase
works pretty well they're all about
frequentist probability a more popular
approach that claims that the only way
you can really know the odds is to have
lots of hard objective data that backs
you up let's say you flip a coin once
and it lands heads based on that you
might assume it's always going to land
heads but that'd be pretty stupid we all
know that the more times you flip a coin
the closer it's going to get the landing
heads just half the time that's the
whole point of frequentist probability
flip that coin enough times and you'll
have good enough data to take on Vegas
to those guys Bayesian probability is
like shooting an arrow half blindfolded
and hoping you hit the target but most
of the time that's exactly where you
find yourself needing an answer without
having much to go on
that's why World War two hero Alan
Turing that nerdy British guy who
dreamed of computers way before Steve
Jobs did used Bayesian probability to
crack top-secret transmissions some of
them sent from their Fuhrer himself
despite this the frequentist still think
Bayesian czar Lane and the rivalry
continues deep into the 20th century
but then the 1980s people had been
trying to make artificial intelligence a
reality since the 60s programming
computers with basic logic like if X is
true then Y happens that approach works
fine as long as X is always true but as
you can guess there are too many unknown
variables in the real world to bring
c-3po to life but then in 1988 Judea
pearl jump-starts AI with a new approach
based on you guessed it phases theory so
that's why in 2011 when a computer
called Watson beat a couple of humans
answering questions on Jeopardy it was
Thomas Bayes running around inside
Watson's brain going if this is true
then that might be true and if that
other thing is true then I'm gonna buzz
in with what is Chicago Alex 250 years
after he flipped his last coin it turns
out phases odds were pretty damn good
you